はい おはようございます
えー私はえー 外人になりまして
帰国で 2年近くが経つんですけれども
また昨日のヴィパッサナー瞑想の質問も
そろそろもうおかげさんに達しようとしているんですけれども
今日も最初の出だしからつまづいてしまったようで
今の話をすると まあちょっと猛威がなくて
そろそろ諦める感じなのかなというような気持ちも抱いて座ってるんですけれども
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の質問の時に
長老は長老は 3時間のうち 2時間を心というものの正義のお話になっていらっしゃいますけれども
その心というものの その出だしのところで最初からつまづいてしまいまして
何がわからないかというと
心とは一体どういうもので
心を清らかにするとか
汚れを落とすとかということは
一体どういうことなのか
よくわからないんですね
長老がお書きになったものまで読ませていただきますと
心というのは 変に目に見えない
不可思議なものなど何でもなくて
普通に話すとか喋るとか食べるとか寝る
そういった行為が心であるよとおっしゃっているように思うんですけれども
そこのところで一番最初の出だしからつまづいて引っかかってしまってて
いる状態なんですけども
ちょっと教えていただけないでしょうか
心っていうのは 喋る 歩く
考える ご飯食べる そういうことでしょうに
喋ってるんだけど それはわからないというのはね
私にはわからないんですけどね
最初から私は思っていたんですけど
あんまりにも妄想するからね
それはやめてください
このままこれほど明確に心があるのに
生きることが心でしょうに
手を上げたり下げたり
歩いたり 心でやってるでしょうに
手を上げることが心で
手は物体で 上げたいという気持ちがあったりするし
感覚があるんだから上げてる
それで心なんですよ だからあるのは心ですよ
物質といえばほんのちっちゃな物質でしょうね
体にあるのは  では心を清らかにするとか
だから汚れは体につくもんじゃないでしょうに
怒りは足につくものですかね
あれはお腹につくものですかね
怒りは心でしょう 感情でしょう
欲張ることっていうのは
手で欲張りますとか ありえないでしょうに
足で欲張りますとかないでしょうに
私は欲張りますと言ったところで
それ心でしょうに だから汚れるのは心で
体は汚れません 体はただの物質ですよ
土でしょうに 土には汚れも綺麗でも何の関係もないんです
例えばご飯は美しいもので
清らかなもので 便は汚いものだというのは
これ心で判断するんであって
物質的に見れば何のこともないでしょ
ご飯がおいしいものや
便は汚いものやとそう判断するのは心でしょうに
ですから この体には綺麗か汚いか
汚れか汚れてないかということはないんです
例えば水が汚れているかないかということはないんですよ
水の立場から見れば しかし
水を飲みたいという心を持っている人にとっては
水が汚れている 水が綺麗やという概念が成り立つだけ
人は美しくても醜いでもないんです
体がそれを見る私の心で
あの人は美しい この人は醜いと判断するんであって
だから汚いのは心なんです
汚れているのは心なんです
例えば我々の体で汗が出て
ホコリが溜まったりする
あ 汚れたと思っちゃうでしょう
本当はもうホコリが溜まっただけ
それ汚れでもなんでもないんですよ
しかし 感覚を持ってる私はそれが嫌やと思っちゃう
体が汚れたと思っちゃう
それは心の問題である
全然お風呂の入らない人もいるんだからね
そういうわけで 問題は心だけ
汚れるのは心 清らかになるのも心
判断するのも心 生きるのも心
食べるのも心 呼吸するのも心
では あの心をきれいにするというのは
綺麗に食べる 綺麗に寝る
綺麗に話す そういったことで理解してもよろしいんでしょうか
うんうん  心を綺麗にする
清らかにするということは
清らかに寝る 清らかに食べる
清らかに話す  まあその理解はいいんですよ
別に この清らかにという単語は何なのかと
汚れた心で食べるか 清らかな心で食べるかということでしょう
例えば 貪瞋痴があって
妄想があって 自我があって
食べる場合は汚れた食べ方
慈しみで溢れた心で食べると清らかな食べ方
歩く場合は これでもう何スマートになって体力をつけてもらって
みんなに見せてやるぞと歩く場合は汚れで歩いてますよ
怠けてはあきません だから人間というのは
人間はちゃんと頑張って人の役に立たなくちゃいけない
ですから 体力をつけるために歩きますよと思ったら
心は綺麗でしょ だからもう清らかに食べる
清らかに寝る 清らかに歩くと言ってもいいんです
清らかっていうのは貪瞋痴がない状態
汚れたっていうことは貪瞋痴がある状態
まあ新しく話聞く人は貪瞋痴わからないかもしれませんけど
貪っていうのはむさぼり
瞋っていうのは怒り 痴っていうのは無知
むさぼりと欲と怒りと無知があると汚れています
心が そうすると食べることも汚れています
歩くことも汚れています
寝ることも汚れています
で 怒り 欲がなく 怒りがなく
無知がない心でやっていると
全部清らかです そういう風に理解してもいいんです
はい ありがとうございます
はいはい ちょっと大きい声で言ってくださいませ
耳が遠いんです  あ どうもありがとうございました
はい  すいません よろしくお願いします
えっと 五道の本で 子供からとか大人とか
ちょっと忘れてしまったんですが
何回か読みました えっと
あの五道の話で何か引っかかったところがあります
うん あの私自身は倫理哲学というものをあまり知らなくて申し訳ないんですけども
こちら美しくまで関わることができて
僕自身はあまりいいことがないのでなんとも言えないですけど
じゃあ うーん まあいわゆるいい男というのは
人生でいいことをしたのかどうかとか
じゃあ 外見に現れるというようなこと
ちょっともっと大きい声で聞こえない
言わないと私聞こえませんよ
はい すいません えーと
自信を持って言ってください
はい えーと 輪廻転生 輪廻転生についてですね
あの仮定を立てないと
業論というのは完全に理解できないのではないかということを一つ質問があります
もう一つは 横山洪一先生の有識の哲学の解説を読みました
ただ これには僕としては致命的な欠陥があるのではないかなと思います
で ちょうどが有識について触れられないのはなぜなのかというのが一つあるんですが
僕の考えとしては 心について執着し過ぎるかなんではないかという推測はしているのですが
こちらの方についてもお聞かせ願えればと思います
今の質問もう一度言ってください
最後だけでいいんです
心に執着しすぎる  ん？ 心に執着しすぎる
あの有識の本を読んでいて
僕の印象では心に執着しすぎるのではないかなと思いまして
質問をさせていただきます
よろしくお願いします
2つ よろしくお願いします
えーと まあ輪廻転生がなくても業論は成り立ちます
だからといって輪廻転生を否定する理由は何なのかということもあります
で 私は信じませんということは理由にはなりません
我々は知らないことっていっぱいありますからね
ですから そこはちょっとペンディングにしてください
世の中ではすべて行為の結果でしょ
それを知ってますかね
何でも行為の結果 行為は 2種類
一つは自然の行為とは言わない
それは一応ファンクションですね
地球が回っているわとかね
それによっていろんな変化が起こるでしょ
それは生命は絡んでないんだからね
地球の回転によって冬になったり
夏になったりする  それはもう行為の結果なんですよ
我々生命がやることを全部行為の結果
行為の結果 行為の結果
これははっきりしています
ですから 行為には結果確実にあるということは業論なんです
だから我々は行為に気をつける
いくらか推測できますよ
こんなことをしたらどんな結果になるのかというね
例えば嘘をついて人を騙したら素晴らしい結果になるわけじゃないんです
騙したっていうことは成功かもしれませんだけど
信頼できない人間になったという結果も帯びています
信頼できない人間になって
世の中で生きていられるのかというと
人を騙して儲かったかもしれませんだけど
社会人として信頼できない人間がという結果得ているんだから
損の方が多いんです だから
常識的にそういうことはやめましょうと
すべては行為の結果です
行為は心でやっています
それから このなんで人間一人一人違うのかということは
なんである人には 例えばベートーベンやらね
無茶才能があって 私ならあれどうやって弾くのかと
わからないもう それは才能ないんですよね
ある人が描いた落書きはもう何百万
億単位で売られて 一生懸命苦労してる
描いた絵画なのに まあ 1 万 2万円しか値段つかないとかね
もう何やこれ やっぱり人は様々バラバラだから
これは一回生まれた 一回で死ぬというイスラム教の教えでは説明できません
で まだ若いんだからね
知らないと思いますけど
できれば生まれて 1ヶ月間の赤ちゃんたちを見てください
一人一人生まれつき性格違うでしょう
それで同じ兄弟なのに
ある人はニンジン嫌いし
ある人はすごいニンジンは好きやとかね
で 同じ兄弟なのに一人がすごく明るくて
一人一人がいつでも気分屋さんでとかね
そういう風にいろいろ性格一人も似てないんですよ
それが長い間の原因結果の流れですっていうのが仏教の話なんです
まあとにかく輪廻っていうのは皆様の知識で理解できるものではないんだから
そこはカットなんです
それは超一流たちや智慧で
お釈迦様が発見されたものだから
まあ自分でも具体的に知りたければ
まあ瞑想するしかないんです
して かなり思考概念を開発するしかないんですけど
一応質問にあったのは
輪廻が信じ 輪廻を信じなくても業論成り立つのかっていうことだから成り立ちます
二番目は唯識の話でしょ
唯識哲学には決定的な弱点がありますので
私は全然相手にしないんです
それは終わりです  なぜ
なぜと聞いたら  なぜ？ なぜなぜと聞いたら
別に聞いてはいけないではなくて
私はそれ以上話したくないということですね
ありがとうございます
はい まあ質問ないそうですから
では終了しましょう  回向の三宝に礼拝致し
戒の守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナーによって得られた功徳を
かみなり 先祖 その両親
親族 恩師をはじめとし
一切の人々にもに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての人々が幸福になりますように
そして偉すが現れますように
サッビーティオーヴィパッジャントーサッバローポーヴィナッサトーマテーパワットアンテラーヨスケーディーガーユコーバワーバウトゥサッバマングラッカンサッバ
デヴァタサッバブンダヌバーヴェーナサッバダンマーヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダースッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリスーニッチャンワッ
ダパチャリーノーチャットルーダンマワッダンテーヤーイワンナースカンバラン
では 長い時間どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました